we begin early at 12 30 p.m
good hedge out there
[Applause]
take it on the side anthony sets this up
top of the key looks off the corner he's
got his head turned to the left to
hassan
porter is covering mccollum now
around the screen they go trent jr way
downtown
and he hits five point lead for the
blazers
and the pass is thrown away by plumbing
trying to get it to porter got to cut
harder got to move his body up
trent jr that's good three for three
from beyond the arc
he is owning the bubble down in orlando
and keeps getting better
gary trent jr and he nails it
he got away with a little bit of a
travel early
and that's the end of the third quarter
the standings
it's damian lillard with gary trent
playing his robin
can the nuggets get a stop here
and gary trent jr wide open can't leave
him open he's a terrific
three-point shooter unless they can get
a life preserver here they're going down
trent man where did this guy came from
both guys good on the perimeter
nerk making an aggressive lunge at the
ball calculated
and then more screen action that's why
that play coming out of the break just
give dame the chance
he doesn't even have to use the screen
he could turn it down when you turn it
down normally if you got a plan of
action
nuggets get a point there they're down
by six it's a two possession game
with 90 seconds to go
gary trent jr now they're leaving him
open
there's this kick out late reacting to a
guy